in time you will know what it's like to
lose thread it run from it
the end is near
we got one advantage we have with anis
once
so that's what we use
I think it's good except it sucks so let
me do the plan and that way it might be
really good Wow today I would don't
fight for oneness
we fight for one of them
Groo put that thing away now I don't
want to tell you again
[Music]
hey everybody we got all kinds of new
marble to break down this morning New
Avengers footage bleeding armor
activation we got a much better look at
Iron Man's new armor and new Winter
Soldier behind the scenes it pretty much
started their press tour so if you
remember the funny videos that they were
posting before Captain America Civil War
those are probably going to start
dropping really soon - because we're
less than a month away from the movie
getting here so if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos I'm doing an Infinity
Gauntlet replica giveaway all you have
to do to enter that just be a subscriber
and leave a comment on the video so
obviously everyone's freaking out about
the bleeding-edge armor the way that it
works looks a lot like the Black Panther
costume albeit with a more Iron Man
twist it looks much more mechanical the
black panther suit is made to look a
little more organic like a blend of
nature and Technology Iron Man is like
the pure technologists so a lot of
people have talked about surety an Iron
Man in their relationship during the
course of the film because they've been
very vague about how much Iron Man knows
about what's going on in Wakanda but I
think we're only a stone's throw from
endow similar depending on whether or
not Iron Man survives these next two
films there's still a big question about
who walks out of these alive but if
you're not a big comic book reader and
you don't know the difference between
the bleeding-edge armor and the endo sim
armor the endo similar is something that
would have to come after a couple big
twists within the Marvel Cinematic
Universe because it's technology that's
based on the symbiote and we haven't has
symbiote inside the Marvel Universe yet
I know that we have venom coming up
there's the Spider Man connection we
still don't know exactly how they're
going to explain that other than it's
gonna be a very planet of the symbiotes
twist where something crashes to earth
the symbiote is inside of it so either
some sort of asteroid or some sort of
invasion somehow the symbiote crash
lands on earth that could be because of
the events of infinity war that's still
wide open for speculation but as you can
see just like black panther suit the
bleeding-edge armor comes via nanites
that come out of the arc reactor that's
in his chest so you have a bunch of
nanites that are housed in there that
formed the armor around him as he needs
it so he does have a biological link
with
his body is integrated with it but it's
not like extremity inside of his bone
marrow the nanites of the bleeding-edge
Armour is sort of a half step on the way
to symbiote where you literally don't
need anything and it can become anything
and it looks kind of like liquid metal
the nanites here it still looks very
mechanical even though it's a big
upgrade from his homecoming armor if
you've even cared you to actually be
here but even though we have a seated in
the trailers yet they have released
pictures you can see wings and
stabilizers that stick out of his back
that's so that he can fly when he's in
orbit or zero-gravity environments
they're just extra weapons that come out
extra layers but it's basically the suit
reforming as he needs it so like his arm
can turn into a blaster but that's not
because he lost his arm
that's just because the nanites that
formed that metal arm reformed into a
cannon that he can then fire that's
where you get to endow same armor so
that armor is directly tied into
people's brains it's based on symbiote
technology so it appears to be a liquid
metal but it's a much more badass
version of what you're seeing happen
with these nanites in the bleeding-edge
armor form around him imagine a much
quicker version of this like when the
symbiote is forming around venom or
forming around spider-man but because
that's Ironman armor you can also form
hand cannons repulsors anything that the
Ironman costumes have been able to do it
can increase its durability so he could
turn into the Hulkbuster he can form
into anything that he wants it to be so
that your one suit becomes like the 50
billion different suits that Ironman is
created in his armory so it negates the
need for having a physical armory that
houses all these different suits but the
other big part of this is we see some
new Scarlet Witch they've been doing a
lot of interviews because the press
tours have started in the directors the
actors have basically said that the
weird romance as they described it
between vision and Scarlet Witch is
meant to be the heart of infinity war
like they're using that as sort of the
emotional through-line of the film that
carries you forward so vision is a
living MacGuffin himself because this
all about the Infinity stones collecting
those to form the Infinity Gauntlet but
sort of hand-in-hand with that they want
to get you to care about the story
because of vision and Scarlet Witch so I
think a lot of your enjoyment of their
storyline just depends on how you feel
about those characters like if you
really don't care about them then you're
probably just here to see the infinity
so it's like I just want to see Thanos
kick everyone's asses I want to see some
funny character interactions and I want
to see that gauntlet but I think that
elizabeth Olsen Paul Bettany they're
great actors they could probably sell it
a little bit and it is fun to see them
do comic book things even if vision and
Scarlet Witch aren't the hugest comic
book characters as they've been
presented so far in the MCU like Scarlet
Witch doesn't have her Chaos magic I'm
really curious to see if she's gonna
lose her [ __ ] like she does in the
comics when vision gets the mine stone
taken from him maybe it looks like he's
dead maybe that trigger sir she kind of
did that when Quicksilver died during
age of Ultron but she wasn't nearly as
powerful then she's way more powerful
now she's way more powerful now so as of
right now the most powerful Avengers
before Captain Marvel shows up are Hulk
and Scarlet Witch mostly because you
don't know what her limits are probably
one of the best things they did was
tying her origin to an infinity stone
because there's so much that we don't
know about it so they could do whatever
they want to with the character like
they could say that she's crazy powerful
and that would make sense because the
Infinity stones are so powerful but just
let me know in the comments what are you
looking forward to from her storyline I
get a lot of Scarlet Witch questions and
yes obviously I think that she's gonna
survive to phase 4 I don't think she's
gonna die during Avengers 4 or anything
like that and I think that she will also
be critical to getting the gauntlet off
of Thanos's hand she's one of the few
people that can actually manipulate the
gems using their power the other
wildcard in all this is obviously gonna
be Captain Marvel but most of what she
was originally going to be doing during
infinity work got pushed to Avengers 4
so it's still wide speculation on what
the origin of her powers are going to be
in how she'll be able to fight Thanos
when he has the full gauntlet assembled
because she does absorb power but the
idea of the Infinity Gauntlet is that
it's the most powerful thing in the
universe
most of that Winter Soldier behind the
scenes it looks like it's just coming
from this outrider invasion Sebastian
Stan has been telling all kinds of jokes
about how he's only read about
ten pages of the actual infinity war
script ten pages where he's actually
speaking most of the rest of it is him
either standing around reacting to stuff
or him in big battle scenes like this
which doesn't require a lot of dialogue
so they did say that a lot of the
dialogue that the actors get during
moments like that when they're just like
running around in big battle scenes was
improvised like they didn't give the
actors more pages of script than they
needed to for their scenes so most of
the actors actually have no idea how the
entire film fits together like they
confirm that there are only five people
on that production that have read the
entire script and that includes the two
Russo brothers in the two screenwriters
which is four people that other one
person may have been Robert Downey jr.
but if you've ever watched the behind
the scenes with him a lot of his
dialogue ends up being improvised like
they'll give him a script so he'll have
an idea for what the character needs to
be doing in the scene but then he'll
just try a bunch of different versions
and make it his own just because he's
that fantastic so big question not
counting Kevin Feige
who's that one other person that got to
read the entire infinity war script
definitely not Mark Ruffalo definitely
not Tom Holland if you guys didn't see
Donald Glover dropped a huge Deadpool
bombed this morning about why the
Deadpool TV series got canceled there
was also a new Deadpool trailer that
just dropped so I'll do a new video for
that next and in that video I'll talk
about what Donald Glover did in this
crazy script that he tweeted out because
it's not actually a script so I'll
explain what's going on with that is
really cool but really WTF at the same
time click here for that other big
infinity war trailer that just posted
and click here for the Deadpool trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]